on this episode ET stops by tell them
Gary
you ask
ha
this is
ask Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is supposed to 23 i'm the
askgaryvee show
don't don't laugh about me screwing up
episode
d-roc I saw that Eric I'm really glad we
did this man like for a long time for a
long time people kept like I would get
these random emails back in the day
saying like hey you're like the small
white version of Eric I'm like who the
[ __ ] is that I was like I was just it
was always really funny to me and
obviously in the last couple months we
connected on digital and I'm glad we
made this happen
I'm glad yeah I've always wanted to see
them Gary I know you guys would know how
we do that like oh one of these days
almost alive I kind of have my bucket I
appreciate it now why don't you tell the
few people that don't know who you are a
little bit about yourself where you come
from how you roll Eric Thomas Mann high
school dropout mom got pregnant with me
at 17 didn't really start talking my
father's I was 30
um I mean I owned I homeless sleeping
abandoned buildings and my god is CJ
maybe they'll just called me from I
don't know if we had 50 sick no sense
also negative sense extra 602 couple
people around like my look this
motivational brand you know from the
bottom up and so now of course we work
with corporate people like you know
Cavaliers with Dan Gilbert sat down with
Warren Buffett you know working the NBA
NFL you know traveling the world doing
this thing so how did it start
so you get CJ and given Kip CJ a little
camera time yeah yeah yeah let's keep
see Jason Cameron tiresome buddy
true it's true listen I know how much
everybody around me matters I think a
lot of people don't know you and I are
lucky because we were gifted with DNA
that allows us to communicate motivate
just you know we're a vessel but there's
a lot of people that make things go so
eleven years ago I sat in a room and
heard does God speak yeah and I watched
like 17 18 19 year old kids like stand
out like like silent they can't even
move and you can tell I was impacting
them I said I don't know what this is I
don't know how we built this into a
company I don't know how we spread this
across the globe but I'm down to die
trying with you God believed in the
message that much sure from that day for
we were just like a heartless figured
out yeah and so how did you get to that
so it was him speaking absolutely so how
do you how do you get there what was
that about College you know it was so
funny
like we would go to these major cities
and these guys that I was with like they
were like you know theology majors and
they would like to speak at these
different places and I wasn't good
enough so I don't speak at like the flea
markets no said I would be how do you
even begin to think about speak first of
all you said you didn't even start
talking to your dad's here 30 you look
30 now how old are you I'm 45 yeah sorry
yeah um so so when did what why didn't
you start speaking at a flea market or
the corner like what did that even have
for me because you know somebody's
spoken to me when I was about 70 years
old and they literally saw this like
when I was 17 sleeping abandoned
buildings not taking showers eating out
of trash cans they were like yo you got
something I was like well what what is
that yo said it was that the first time
you're like first time yeah it was an
older man was like yo you can do it so
he helped me get my GED sent me out to
college and who once the Smith name was
our PC Willis it was a pastor at a local
church that I kind of went to every now
and then one of my own boys and it was
just unbelievable he helped me get my
GED sent me 780 miles away from you Trey
and I just got in a new environment in
college and once I got there I was just
like I was so grateful that I had to pay
it forward so I was like you know what
this guy did for me I've got to do unto
others and that's what I've been doing
just speaking life into people who just
don't believe that they can do know so
many people think that like you have to
have a mother or
your life now you have to go to a
certain school you have to and I don't
believe that I believe when you wake up
and you're ready to like live at that
point I can help you to get from where
you are to where you want to be that's
why I say you know some people think you
know you look at certain successful
people maybe their father's passed
something down or their mothers passed I
was like no it doesn't make a difference
if they pass it down or not everybody's
got to wake up and grind and if you're
willing to work like that we're going to
work you can have whatever you want
agreed so like one thing that is
interesting to me sitting here something
literally popped in my mind which is I
don't know if you ever heard this your
crews ever heard this I I so associate
myself as a businessman right like I
build businesses and I happen to be
motivational I was sitting here and I
was like you know it
I always say your truth is what has to
be done I think a lot of people want to
be motivational speakers like coaches
there's money in it it seems like well I
don't know I'm just gonna tell you and
like wow right
and I'm sitting here like hmm you know
here's a guy who does the motivational
thing I don't really love associating
that much with motivational thing I
don't know why I feel good about it and
then you're telling I don't know your
story at all I don't know anything I'm
like very weird I just go with whatever
I feel and then and I'm sitting her like
huh truth again he was motivated by a
man that became his gateway and and he's
scratching his own itch he's
reverse-engineering saluting and for me
here's the deal a lot of people say et
is motivation to be really ill not
geared what are you I started as an
educator yeah so I got a degree in
education I started with a GED program
yeah I was just great at the GED program
great I think that's where people go
wrong people think that it is a
profession that makes you great it's not
I believe you have to be great and you
change whatever you're doing and you
make that thing do you get mad when you
how do you process when somebody says
you're in motivation I give piss because
it's like oh like don't minimize me like
I totally don't make me into that like I
taught a GED program like you build
businesses ideal people yeah I just have
to be able to talk about what I do like
you can't talk about what they do I just
talk about whatever I feel people
put me in a room with somebody that's
about to get a divorce I guarantee they
won't get one you put me in a room with
somebody or four or or they might write
because I assume cuz this is what I do
when I motivate or try to mold I'm
trying to reverse engineer to the truth
some people should get a divorce yeah I
feel nothing you see not just sometimes
people get like I don't want a divorce
when I sit and listen right or or or
Melissa or I assume you do this maybe
I'm wrong but no I'm not coz you
wouldn't be here if you were you listen
people walk in there like I don't want
this to happen I listen for 20 minutes
I'm like no no you do want that to
happen
right like huh it's very interesting all
right
now Andy what are you doing here this is
not India that's not the professor
what were you were you know I this is
this is I'm just he's never asking the
questions are you just excited like no
why are you here and yet some projects
yet aboard Oh India got fancy all right
what's the first question cuz I'm used
to hurt yeah yeah yeah that's like he's
not as pretty issues no he's really not
video cuz was your backup your password
was crazy what is that you're like let's
go back respect all right let's say boys
bye hey Gary
heyy teets Byron Lezyne I appreciate you
guys taking the question I'm about to go
into the gym here it's 5:45 trying to
get my hustle on my question into Gary
last week and I hope whoever's editing
this will throw in my my youtube channel
here trying to add a little bit of
exposure but you guys been such big
inspiration to me et I found you a
number of years ago the talk you did to
that classroom inspired the crap out of
me I've watched over a hundred times
Gary the first time I saw you was a
keynote to Remax you ripped their faces
off and I'm going to be giving a keynote
actually or rather an 18-minute talk at
the tom ferry summit next week this is
the Super Bowl of all real estate
conferences I've done two three four
hundred person talks but this is in
front of 5,000 people what advice you
have for me stepping up into the big
leagues and guys I'd also like to know
when you're speaking career really
launched were you out pushing that or
did you let all those paid speaking
opportunities come to you how do you
grow a paid
speaking business thanks guys you are
Eric what what what would you feel that
lets answer good you go first year so
first of all I want to say is you know
because we talked about that first
speech again GERD I wasn't doing that
for the world it's an accident that that
video came out like I had no idea that
somebody was recording and put on
YouTube actually a guy recorded it for
his thesis yep never used it for his
thesis okay so I don't the only reason
he might me up is because when was the
lab this was 10 years ago actually the
anniversary to the Guru story is this
school year so that's what I did it
right now is your break out that was the
break out well we say break up we mean
to the world I had two careers the first
one was I've been doing this a hundred
percent yeah I've been with people
people people like oh you broke out I
was like yeah I worked every day my life
I'm finally broken killed broken because
breaking out like punting anything that
was happy and fun and easy and just
grinding my face off yeah I broke out
yet so for me that that speech was to
about forty or fifty kids from the inner
city who are about to get kicked out of
Michigan State and I was going off I was
just going off because it's like they
don't have three chances I get parents
you know just got laid off before Jim
and crisis we're talking about when the
country hit the recession these kids
parents have lost their job GM for
Chrysler all crashes this is their
chance to get a degree and they're
bullshitting so I'm going off course
what happens are recorded especially cuz
you know I'm gonna I'm gonna use that as
my answer which is when you tell your
truth it's it's not scary to talk to one
it's not scared to talk to 50,000 you
ask me right now to read your email
right now if you gave me a long email
and said read it I'd be scared shitless
you know why I'm bad at reading I don't
like reading it's not what comes natural
to me it's it's it's like like I'm [ __ ]
I can go speak in front of this whole
city this whole thing eight give me 80
million people I'm ready give me the mic
I'm going I'm ready right now you asked
me to read in front of this inner circle
I'm like you know let's go let's go get
a drink guys like like now that's stupid
let's do business like
like it's unbelievable so to Brian Brian
Oh Byron Byron just go speak your truth
the biggest mistake people make and
you're by accents similars me I was a
businessman just going a conference I
don't know like you know the number one
reason people fail is because they have
to think yeah and when you think because
you don't know cuz you're trying to fake
it you know you know it's easy for us
and yours is more extreme than mine but
I have my version of it when you're not
at any plateau when you've been there
like nothing super scary I'm what you're
gonna laugh at me like when when like
kids made me drink pee cuz I couldn't
speak English like like things aren't
scary what is somebody gonna do to you
like be like like when you're eating
[ __ ] out of the [ __ ] corner like
what's who's gonna do what somebody's
gonna laugh at you at a conference they
didn't like the way you curse like I
mean that's the silly like so I think I
think the biggest thing is to talk your
truth Byron don't don't try to act
bigger than you are everybody does that
oh now that I'm a big stage let me make
pretend or embellish that I built sold a
lot of apartments or or or you know
people embellish or fake it and then
you're and then you're scared you're
scared something's gonna call you out on
it you're scared somebody's gonna come
you know what I'm pissed about I'd tire
right now I'm getting my report card
right now sent to me my report cards
from high school because somebody in the
comments section of Facebook said Gary
you weren't that bad of a student from
high school only because I think they
liked me and they didn't want to believe
I was such a bad student I'm like oh you
think so let me go get him you know like
so I just think it's truths yes and I
would say to him as well you know give
him something man like too many people
spend so much time talking about their
accomplishments and what they've done
give them something give them a tool to
do that they can literally take I'm
talking about a stupid like don't don't
I listen to some of these guys no
disrespect but it takes about 18
messages before you actually say
something to me right
so I'm saying do me a favor just give
them one or two things and as soon as
the conference is over they can
literally take with them Ashley your
Superman you said that because you're
more right than what I was saying it's
more important than your truth even
though that this doesn't sound like it I
believe that 90% of talks in public
today are
best releases for that person and
they're doing propaganda for themselves
and then they just leave absolutely I'm
I'm trying to guilt [ __ ] to
love amigo that I gave them so much that
they're like damn like that I like
honestly you know what I like about
Kendrick Lamar what do you like about
kitchen I like I like though we got a
nice little cadence going here uh I like
that would I feel like I feel like if I
was good enough to be a rapper I would
have the same mindset what I think he
does and I don't know if this has been
talked about again I don't read anything
so I don't even know if this is out
there I assume it is because it's so
obvious he goes and goes on other
people's albums and he's trying to steal
those fans like when I listen to how he
does it I'm like I get that I literally
Eric I swear to God I go to every
conference and I'm trying to make
anybody that came there for somebody
else question that person I want them be
like damn I can't cuz they're laughing
explain that though explain okay I go to
every conference and I go look it's is a
conference there's this fancy person
there's Warren Buffett there's Tony
Robbins there's Eric Thomas I'm sure
they a lot of people can I'm not the
only person but I'm gonna go on stage
and make every single person leave
saying I don't like Warren Buffett
anymore yeah I like Gary Vee yeah like
I'm trying to go and by the way that's
not by having bravado
that's not having that's not cursing
that's I'm gonna provide so much stream
of value so hard and so long that
they're gonna be tired when I'm done Big
Valley and that's why you know here he
is like ruined you guys gotta hear that
because a lot of you to that study
studying Gary Vee this is why a lot
laughs Gary there are people who look up
to you who don't do what you do you mean
everybody you mean everybody they're
like do you know many people tweet
hustle and work six hours a day like I
know I know
I'm seeing somebody now you're close to
today ask me about my schedule I told
him the schedule and they asked me why
are you up so early
yeah let's move the next question for I
get angry
by the way real quick I got angry
if you ever say to somebody else why are
you up so early that is the quickest
tell - you are not a winning player and
that has ever crossed your mind
you've lost good i ke asks as a rapper
what are the best marketing tips to
implement should I treat music like an
entrepreneur would is product I would
just say exactly with you know Gary 74
just add value you know think about a
specific group of people because you
can't reach everybody you know I'm just
being real I don't care how good you are
at what you do you pick your poison you
pick a group and you just pour into that
group so that every time they listen to
you like Gary said like I'm not a bi I
must be honest like I might get out of
this into anything
I don't read anything but I got hooked
on his Beyonce song and I better listen
to that song this morning I was to do it
it's like I can't put it down and it's
not because it's Beyonce like no
disrespect but it's not because of what
you think but when I hear the song I
hear I was here so waking up before like
you get to get a beat show you got to be
present like not just there you got a
press it cuz you may only get to do this
one more time so I'm listening to her
song and I felt like she wrote it for et
so if you're gonna do [ __ ] find out we
should act - man everybody let's find
out if B wrote it for you you think she
did Abu is your listen I think I think I
think way too many people I'll give you
my advice I think you need to make
pretend not make pretend let me rephrase
you haven't made it I don't think this
was Jay Cole asking the question right
so you haven't made it so stop being
fancy I am stunned by the fanciness in
the market of speakers authors
entrepreneurs athletes and definitely
rappers because I got a ton of them
you're trying to be big-time you think
acting like it is that you know how you
be you have you promote music make one
person every day like your music you
know how you do that by liking them
first by by literally going to Twitter
I'll give you something real tangible
twitter.com so by lovers I love it
winter calm / sir
twitter.com slash search go search
people
you got your opinion of who you are as a
rapper go search people talking about
you know future you think that's your
style jump in and say yeah I like that
track too yes I love that hook when et
tweets that Beyonce spoke to me jump in
and be like yeah that part like become
part of the community everybody wants
everybody to love them love the
community first then they'll love you
back
guilt them into loving you oh that's so
oh look guys that first video for real I
have you be shocked at the millions of
people that one video has 38 million
views you'll be shocked that I did not
do that on purpose you'd be shocked that
I did what Gary you just said I pour
into that community for about 18 years
and then boom all of a sudden one day
that seed blossom into a tree - I'm 18
years doing the right thing is always to
raise hell I'm also said - whoever you
are don't no don't don't do it Gary
you're saying and think that six months
you gonna see the results or here just
because he told you that he didn't tell
you to do that six month later lot honey
how do you think about patience
I mean it's life it's it's everything is
I'm a big big big pusher of pain upset
because you don't know results you can
only work the process you know you don't
know when to privacy do you know what
I'm most fascinated about everybody
there right now how many people gave up
a month before it was gonna happen like
like I don't worry that the what happens
when you die and you let go talk to God
God's like yo listen I got to show you
something you gave up on March 19 1994
it was gonna happen on April 7th 99 and
you're like what like I'm fascinated by
lack of patience alright let's go move
on Jacob brown asks as a PhD what
percentage would you contribute of where
you are today to your degree absolutely
zero zero I didn't get the PhD for
success I got the PhD for the patients I
got the PhD for the process when did you
get your PhD last year May did you think
you like you know what this is a real
good opportunity on a real serious cake
I think what makes this show good as
I'm super not scared talk talk me
through the PhD did you feel that that
was a smart strategic thing to create a
little more air cover so that you had
more room to do your thing so so for
real free I don't know for me Gary that
I was trying to and when I first walked
in you talked about business yep right
and I told you I build people yes but
building people doesn't always pay well
I understand that so I had I had to put
myself in a different market
I understand then what I originally
wanted tell me when I started right but
what happens when you're from Detroit
like I am want to be most segregated
cities United States of America I did
not have the cold the language of the
rules to get in the game that I wanted
to play that's right so for me Michigan
State gave me an opportunity yes to go
to class and hear that language to give
it an environment for six years and be a
part of the rules so you can't play the
game if you don't know the game so so
the degree to me was about it doesn't
make Detroit bad it doesn't make my
community bad but there are some things
I need to operate on this level
interesting that you even what went
there it's that's I'm so fascinated that
you said that
I'm fascinated that in your mind it
processed that this thing could be a
counter move to making that thing look
bad it's an actually massive insight
that people grossly underestimate it's a
thing that I grew up with in a different
way you know I came to this country
because Jews were persecuted in the
Soviet Union like my parents and
grandparents grew up in an environment
where they were blamed for the world war
my grandparents might both my
grandfather's went to jail for being
Jewish and I think that people don't
understand that being a minority
somewhere Jewish in Europe African
American in America there's a psyche
that people understand which is you hear
you hear us white guys here here selling
out you know you know you know Uncle Tom
getting away from it's so much deeper
than you think so and and let me tell
you where I'm going with it I'm actually
going a very left turn on this most of
you are so molded by your parents you
can't even wrap your head around it and
there are certain things your pair
put in you that you are scared to break
against because you don't want to let
them down even though you might hate
your parent or what have you it's
unbelievable to me that you went there
that the success of PhD had to be hedged
in your mind through your words that
that's not bad on Detroit that to me is
such an insight that we need to have a
conversation in general about people
understanding that having something good
happen doesn't trigger a negative event
somewhere else and that is something
we're all dealing with in our own
versions and so for me it was like 'hey
if you can't get certain arenas you
can't operate on if you don't know it
like you got you can't play football if
you don't like it here here's the thing
i hate i okay so what i do for a living
I hate gear did a God thinks he's gonna
do what I've done for 27 years he's
gonna watch my videos he's gonna do it
for five months five years and boom he's
an ex II team wait a minute II just cuz
you mean you can't register seven figure
mastermind Instagram account and become
that yeah I mean it's real so I'm saying
II don't realist
I realize that et you have what you
think is success but you get that PhD
you're gonna understand like it's like
another language Gary it's like another
language like another word you like
being a student I love I love that you
know that's not reading oh yeah it was
interesting I don't like the reason yeah
yeah yeah no it's interesting it's
interesting huh I like that okay well
what was the question
as a PhD what person got it okay 0 0 K
good 0 what up what up issue boy Zayn
coming from Sydney Australia and welcome
to the show ET I believe this is a huge
issue for a lot of people in life and my
question is where does motivation stop
and execution again I want to take this
opportunity to thank you both for being
huge influences in my life and I can
proudly say that I wouldn't be the man I
am today if it wasn't for you - that's
very nice Z squared I will tell you that
the amount of people that come in and
right notes all day little notebooks of
motivation spend ungodly amounts of
hours the amount of hours that we've
spent watching each other stuff I don't
to speak for you my gut is 0/0 full
hours you know like it's [ __ ] like like
I don't know I don't know but here's
what I can tell you some people need to
be motivated for me I didn't
I got a chip on my shoulder and that
thing will drive me into a dam in the
ground I'm so motivated it's coming out
of my face right like so I don't need
that so I can't speak for everybody
everybody's got different versions but
here's what I can tell you there's a
sign in here that is driving everybody
crazy it's brought up like four times
the last week it says ideas are [ __ ]
this is hangs in our office and it's
driving people crazy and the reason I
don't finish my statement in that sign
is I want people to think because the
sign actually reads if it was in its
full entirety ideas are [ __ ] until you
execute them
where does motivation stop and start
everybody's got a different answer but
here's what I can tell you it's really
easy to be motivated either you've got
it or you can watch it it's really hard
to execute it is the variable that
separates people people are always going
to tell me every day every day I roll up
on people they're like yo I'm gonna buy
the Seahawks and you're gonna buy the
Jets and I'm like great can't wait to
see you people are always telling me
that they're going to do this so that
and this and that and you know what I do
I don't know if you do this I ask lots
of them to email me in 60 days in 90
days in a year and you know how many do
juice egg people talk [ __ ] and I don't
know where it stops or starts but I know
that most of you 99% of you aren't going
to do anything about it
and that sucks I'm with your inhale
exhale is like asking me which one is
which I don't know which one is with you
idiot
yes I don't know which one is first
which one is second but if you got
executed you're not motivation like I
don't know what that other stuff is
you're doing but real motivation I don't
know which one comes first but it makes
you do something like if you're not
doing anything you're not really
motivates a little bit Star Wars like I
just went somewhere weird I'm sitting
here like you know the truth is don't
you think don't you think motivation
comes a little bit from a little bit of
Darkness like like like this is this is
my point you know this is fun
this in this room and I've been talking
to I was talking a bunch of female
entrepreneurs the other day and some
leaders in my company there's a lot of
mixed genders in here I actually I you
know and again I'm so scared to go here
because I rep I understand where I'm
going I don't know I think having being
a minority being an underdog is an
advantage I can't not believe that I
like I genuinely believe I'm making this
for my son Xander I think you're soft I
think you're watching this right now six
years from now I think you're going to
cut text me in a few minutes to be like
yo I'm going to kill you which I hope
because I hope you have that in you but
the truth is I just believe that it's
that Andy's in a disadvantage I just
genuinely believe that to lose I just I
don't know how else to say it now
that's we step by the way that's me
stereotyping if Andy's lucky to be
motivated something bad happened he had
a oh I don't know his dynamic lose
brother but like I think being a younger
brother is a great one right like I said
give me show me a kid who walks in here
and says I'm like what's your story well
I grew up super rich and white and it's
awesome and I keep going there like well
my older brother was a star football
player and I wasn't like okay now like I
started right I'm like show me something
I think I think motivate I think a lot
of you are not motivated because you're
luckier and what I mean by that is
you're lucky in different ways you
haven't dealt with the adversity that
much uh and by late it's not a
black-white thing girl/boy thing it's
you just had great parents you had a
good upbringing like life just didn't
give you that much adversity and so I
don't know you like I want to slice
throats like like I don't know like my
stuff is super evil like I'm being
really honest with you guys today I go
to the conference everybody's in the
green room friends friends I'm like I'm
gonna slice your throat like you're
gonna go up there and people gonna clap
I'm gonna go up there and people gonna
hate you after you'd be like why don't
even clap for the guy before me that
like that's what's going through my mind
of course it's just not a nice thing no
quiet look do you know why people hate
that when I have guests on it just
happened right now I int route what
you're supposed to hear I can't help ya
are you ready to go I was gonna sit okay
everybody's like Anna wait your son
you're so engaged with your daughter cuz
my father wasn't there I'm not
the father I just didn't have my father
so every day I wake up that drives me
I'm not going to be here every time I
get on the mic it's like my people
didn't take it all of us talk no
watching back so I'm taking it back
so I'm with you it's the dark side it's
the I didn't have I ate out of trash can
I told the kids yesterday in the NBA I
said look everybody can get but can you
keep so for me I say I'm not into money
I just don't want to go back to being
homeless I don't want to eat out of
trash cans again I don't want to sleep
in a bag do so I'm so it's the darkness
in me that gets me up and drives I
genuinely believe the worst thing in
life is to be somewhere grow and then go
backwards now I'm weird because I'm also
weirdly romantic to it like that rocky
where he loses everything he's back
there's a part of me that's always like
ooh if I lose everything I've got I'll
rise back and and then I'll realize who
my real friends were and you will not
want to be my friend anymore good when I
rise back up a good [ __ ] you like you
know like I know I think you think so I
think so
let's go to next game Oh Aaron Perez
asks enroute to self-awareness do you
believe we find ourselves or create
ourselves well it's a deep question how
self-aware do you think you are if I ask
you that yeah me too
baby who do you think who do things more
somewhere mirror you me you know what I
feel you know you know what I feel of
course I feel like I generally think I'm
the most self-aware person earth okay oh
my god but do you do you do you feel
just I'm texting you at 2:53 tomorrow
morning and I haven't even gone to sleep
yet so so what that's a really nice
question what do you think yeah no no I
believe I believe that you know write
our book we just came up with average
skill phenomenal wheel is that your
first book third book how are you in
book world you're good at it yeah we
could amber you're very good well how
good yeah uh what do you mean under
rather zygoma rocks real
self-published up from the garage like
what like like open up the trunk and
selling it from the back absolutely love
it
yeah I'm kidding so about first have you
ever considered going mean publishing we
have like the numbers not obvious when
we started out we had such a big phone
that one of the supporters like off the
back right will buy it as soon as it
comes out at $25.99 yeah you know we
will talk you're like why don't share
with other people I go [ __ ] right there
like okay four dollars but we're like
yeah yeah totally understand so for us
in our third book average kill phenomena
will underdog we believe that you don't
have to have a phenomenal steal but if
you have a phenomenal wheel you're not
going to quit you not gonna stop you'll
be successful the very first challenge I
think I'm more serious about the very
first chapter is self-awareness very
first job really because you know what's
funny about my book yeah I talk about
who's more serious my book
self-awareness in my [ __ ] title
I'm putting my title you got chapters I
got titles you got chapters I got titles
you know I think it's a really
interesting question I think that's one
that we'll never really fully figure out
I'm always wondering was this my destiny
or did I mentally create it I think it's
a very fine line I definitely think
there's elements of both and I'm a big
believer in momentum I'm sure as you
started feeling it and it you know
momentum is real I you know what I do
think a lot of things like I think about
sports and you see that athlete who
matured a little bit late right and had
a big second year and then all of a
sudden like wait a minute like you know
it's funny I started a sports agency
called Vayner sports
we just started we're recruiting kids
and I'm talking these kids I'm like when
did you think that you could be a pro
right they're like juniors right now
seniors about to come out and a lot of
them are like after this one game my
sophomore year like like multiple people
said it okay or after one big game right
or one my homie went to the league and I
was dogging them in practice I'm like
wait a minute Jerome's going on elite
like you know like like it like it's soo
right yeah and so and then but what's
interesting what I'm trying to make the
connection is when they said that when
they made the decision that they could
go into the league
everything changed they worked out more
they play better
they ate better they went down to one
girlfriend instead of seven
one man I was having time when he said
that you know but it's funny it was the
mental decision that created their
actions I got my health together two
years ago it was a mental game that I
got there now I'm there it's very meta I
don't think we talked about the brain
enough in our society and I think that's
gonna be a big subject that will
discover I think people look back at
some of the things we talked about and
others 100 years ago now be like wow
they were early on to understanding how
much the brain could do versus all the
other intangibles
all right UT you get to ask the question
of the day any question you want
who is the vaynernation and all your
fans you get to ask question and then
the YouTube comments and facebook
comments people will answer it what's
the one you know you didn't get a
thousand answers you've got a good sense
of where our crossovers are what
question do you want to ask not maybe
then you go ahead ask me and then think
about go ahead you guys answer my
questions well go ahead so so the one
crossover yeah I do know like when you
look at basketball yeah you got a guy's
just dribbling driven everything one day
he crosses over yeah saying he feels
like this is my yes this is mine what
was your crossover for you what was that
like you my first baseball card show I
kept so glad you asked this it's not
something we've ever really expanded on
I may be told it once I'm curious if you
guys even know it my first baseball card
show was in eighth grade and the
Phillipsburg mall had a baseball card
show and I'm like we're gonna do it I'm
gonna do my face I'm gonna do my
baseball card show and I went on Friday
after school it was a Friday Saturday
and Sunday show but I was still in
school so I couldn't do the Friday but I
wanted to get a table for Saturday
Center and I go Friday to the promoter
and this big fat guy comes out like
400-pound guy right look like like
avalanche from WWF like big guy like you
know tugboat like big guy and I go are
you the Pirotta goes yeah I go kick can
me my friends get a table for the show
he goes the show started I'm like no no
for Saturday and Sunday you know it's
like real combative I'm like look I like
four foot seven like 84 pounds you know
and and I'm like no no we want a table
and on the drive there this is the punch
line on the drive there we made a pact
like all hands in
it's $100 or less we'll do it and if
it's more we're not doing it super pact
Blood Brothers like this is what we're
gonna do we get there this man goes sure
three hundred dollars and then before he
said dollars I said we'll take it
shake hands we walk out of the mall and
they're just looking at me like and I
was like I was like it three hundred
dollars was like you know like I was
like we got I'm like we'll do it I was
nervous this and at first we get in
Saturday morning 7:00 a.m. doughnuts the
malls not open yet we're setting up or
excited I'm like gonna fall I can speak
in front of 8 million people I'm not
gonna feel that energy like I felt there
was my first you know and I walk that
whole mall I walked it I looked at
everybody's tables I memorized memorized
everybody's prices on every card I came
back to my table and I lowered every one
of my prices a dollar cheaper than the
lowest price across the whole show on
every single card and then I hustled and
by midday by like 12 1 o'clock were
there for four hours mall was open we
had already made all our money back and
more the night before my dad who never
talked to me ever it just worked I'm
just my dad at no relationship my dad
came up to me I told my mom I was
nervous and like holy SH ed my dad came
up to me and I love my pops race he just
said it to me a great learning
experience I didn't understand I was
like what does it mean stupid you know
anyway that was it that night I went to
sleep and I was in eighth grade
and I had already been pumping school
since fourth or fifth grade but that
night I went to sleep and I said I'm
gonna be great I'm set and I've never
wavered since so that's Fame what's your
story
what's your crossover moment you keep
asking questions we'll keep answering
them